the name of Chloe's baby is revealed but
we're still shook over Beyonce at
Coachella guys the dust has finally
settled at Coachella and I'm still
coughing it all up but I'm also piecing
together my wig after Beyonce blew it
and us all the way we'll get to that in
just a few but first we got to get into
some other big news today Khloe
Kardashian just revealed the name of her
little girl
say hello to true Thompson Khloe posted
this shot with a very pink room with the
message quote mommy and daddy love you
true so guys first thoughts on the
baby's name I know some of you guys
suggested Khloe keep Kardashian in the
name that didn't happen but she is
keeping the alliteration alive also is
clearly trying to tell us something
but true that the alleged cheating
rumors are true or that it's true love
because we despite all the infidelity
drama that went down last week between
khloe and tristan a source tells ET
chloe is trying to keep the peace with
tristan for the sake of their newborn
daughter our source says quote she and
tristan aren't arguing and things have
been surprisingly very calm adding that
Khloe wants to raise their baby girl in
LA but for now she will go back and
forth from Cleveland we're also told her
33 year old has no plans to leave
Tristan and that she doesn't know what
to believe
well apparently her sisters have taken
sides because our source also says Kim
and Kourtney believe Chloe deserves
better so what do you guys think should
Chloe stay with Tristan for the sake of
their baby girl or kick him to the curb
to the left to the left see what I did
there
because it wasn't all bad news bears
this weekend as the world watch Beyonce
make history at Coachella I was there in
the crowd I still got my wristbands on I
was losing my breath voice and my mind
and all I got was this lousy t-shirt
actually it's really dope and I love it
our queen had everybody talking about
her tour de force showing at the
Coachella Music & Art Festival over the
weekend I mean she brought the house
down by taking us to a good
old-fashioned homecoming
for the first time ever Beyonce was
backed by more than a hundred and fifty
dancers and marching band members who
helped rearrange her classics and
flawless sync collegiate style
baki five costume changes and one near
wardrobe malfunction Beyonce set was
packed with surprises jay-z joined his
wife on stage for a performance of deja
vu before she reunited with Kelly
Rowland and Michelle Williams for a
medley of some of Destiny's Child's
greatest hits
[Music]
then be got a little help from her
sister Lodge
[Applause]
and for her part cardi be proved on
Sunday that you're never too pregnant to
twerk Beyonce and cardi held it down for
they're working at Mama's I mean they
slayed guys meanwhile Justin Bieber well
he made news that Coachella too but for
a very different reason
and I witnessed lzt Justin stepped in to
help a woman who was being assaulted by
another man and he ended up punching the
guy in the face earlier in the weekend
though Biebs was spotted hanging with
the yodeling kid who made a surprise
appearance during we thinset I repeat
yodeling kid was at Coachella needless
to say it was a wild weekend and I can't
believe I'm going back for round two
this weekend so I need a nap but in the
meantime hit subscribe and I'll be back
tomorrow with more Jimmy jr. good night
[Music]
you